[Música]
mar volvemos con nuestra crónica de
salud interrumpida por lo que está
ocurriendo en bruselas por los líderes
políticos pues reunidos estas reuniones
para hablar de lo que ocurre en ucrania
pero hoy se conmemora el día de la lucha
contra la tuberculosis porque
particularmente también el día de hoy
claro hay noticias que a veces no son
tan urgentes pero que son muy
importantes hay un millón y medio de
muertes por tuberculosis al año entonces
por eso y vamos a dedicar este espacio a
contar la historia de esta enfermedad y
pues como decía estupor que se conmemora
hoy porque hace 130 años un científico
alemán llamado robert koch descubrió la
bacteria que causa la tuberculosis algo
que cambió la historia de esta
enfermedad y de su lucha pero también
toda la historia de la ciencia este es
de robert koch que ven aquí en sus
pantallas por qué fue tan importante
este descubrimiento pues porque se
enmarca en el avance de la ciencia de
finales del siglo 19 de lo que se llamó
la teoría germinal o teoría microbiana
es decir es cuando se demostró que hay
enfermedades que las causan organismos
como los virus o las bacterias tan
pequeños que el ojo humano no las puede
detectar en este momento nos puede
parecer muy evidente y más después de
una pandemia de coronavirus pero hasta
ese momento la verdad es que se
consideraba la teoría predominante es
que las enfermedades venían provocadas
por algo que llamaban desequilibrios de
los humores o también incluso de las
emanaciones del inframundo o del suelo y
que eso era lo que enfermaba a la gente
esta idea no cambia hasta finales del
siglo 19 es decir que es un cambio
relativamente reciente y por supuesto
descubrir esta bacteria fue el paso
indispensable a dar para descubrir
también cómo tratar la tuberculosis que
recordemos es una enfermedad tratable
con antibióticos antes de eso las curas
eran altamente ineficientes entonces
pues la verdad es que esta enfermedad se
convertía en la causa en una de las
principales causas de muerte en todo el
mundo una enfermedad muy común para ese
entonces era el día a día más claro
hablamos por ejemplo de lo que era el
siglo 19 1817 también y sobre todo a
raíz de la revolución industrial con la
aglomeración de las personas se calcula
que la tuberculosis mataba una de cada
siete personas tanto en europa como en
eeuu y entre ellos grandes personajes
pues de la literatura del mundo de las
artes edgar allan poe kafka y también
los personajes por ejemplo satin en
moulin rouge la imagen que se la vea ya
tosiendo sangre en ese momento eso era
tuberculosis fantín del emmy llega
también sufría de esta enfermedad y de
hecho como vemos en este texto de
charles dickens que tenemos aquí se veía
hasta con un punto romántico no se veía
la enfermedad porque sobre todo no sabía
que era contagiosa como una enfermedad
que refinaba el aspecto más repugnante
de la muerte citando textualmente este
texto de charles dickens una una imagen
que de hecho dura hasta hoy en día
debido también a esta imagen que tenía
en la literatura y en el cine y que
además la encasilla como una enfermedad
del pasado pero la verdad raúl es que la
tuberculosis no es una enfermedad ni del
pasado ni con esta aura tan romántica
que le otorgamos hablamos del pasado
pero hablemos ahora el presente en
actualidad cuál es la situación de la
tuberculosis marc pues la verdad es que
hemos mejorado mucho sigue siendo la
segunda enfermedad infecciosa que causan
más muertes en el mundo sólo después del
cobat 19 de hecho la organización
mundial de la salud calcula que cada día
y 100 personas pierden la vida por culpa
de esta enfermedad una enfermedad que
recordemos que es tratable y que además
se puede curar esta percepción de que ha
desaparecido en realidad se corresponde
a que se ha reducido mucho su peso y su
carga en los países con recursos en los
países del norte global pero en cambio
los 30 países donde más carga de
tuberculosis hay en el mundo están todos
por ejemplo con algunas excepciones en
áfrica y en asia pues por el difícil
acceso a medicamentos por malas
condiciones de higiene y por un pobre
sistema inmune llama la tensión que será
una enfermedad tratable porque ese es
posible erradicar la porque no se ha
erradicado todavía mar claro es posible
erradicar la pero la verdad es que no
vamos por un buen camino de hecho en el
2020 fue el primer año en muchas décadas
que en las casas de tuberculosis
aumentaron en vez de disminuir como lo
decíamos al inicio un millón y medio de
personas murieron sin embargo los
diagnósticos se redujeron y eso se cree
que es debido a la interrupción pues
también provocada por la pandemia de
kobe 19 eso hace temer que hay mucha
gente que tiene la tuberculosis pero que
no ha sido diagnosticada y recordemos si
las personas no están tratadas de
tuberculosis y contagiar al menos 12
personas cada año y además si no se
trata la tasa de mortalidad de la
tuberculosis es de un 50% vamos nos
encaminamos a la erradicación seamos
optimistas cuáles son los retos y los
desafíos muy brevemente para terminar
delineando estos retos del futuro uno es
la resistencia a los antibióticos del
hecho de que el tratamiento para la
tuberculosis dure entre 4 o 6 meses o
incluso más hace que la bacteria está en
la que hablábamos al inicio pues haya
desarrollado mucha resistencia a los
antibióticos que se usan para tratar lo
segundo la intersección peligrosa entre
la tuberculosis y el vih la tuberculosis
es la principal causa de muertes en
personas que tienen sida precisamente
pues porque este virus daña el sistema
inmune y último la vacuna hay una vacuna
que existe que puede tratar la
tuberculosis sobre todo en niños pero
para adultos es muy ineficaz entonces la
verdad es que la organización mundial de
la salud recomienda que si queremos
erradicar esta enfermedad en el futuro
tenemos que investigar más y encontrar
nuevos tratamientos y nuevas vacunas y
ojalá nosotros aquí en salud de irait o
américa de france 24 podamos hacer ya
está enferma esta enfermedad está
erradicada que no tome tanto tiempo mar
muchísimas gracias nos vemos mañana con
más vamos hasta